there's a vacancy in washington and that
man if you're watching on nbcsn wants to
fill it rex ryan fired by the jets fired
by the bills working at espn wants back
in
and he made it clear appearing on espn
earlier this week of course i would take
it people are going to be lined up for
this job now
i i don't know that people who have
viable options elsewhere are going to be
lined up for the job chris i think it's
a given that this is the most
dysfunctional team in the nfl but when
you aspire to get the job you got to be
able to kiss some butt and he's already
started the process of kissing butt by
saying people are going to be lined up
for the job well yeah i mean i'm not
shocked to hear him say this i mean yeah
okay and then there's only 32 of these
jobs out there in the in the world and
uh even as dysfunctional as it might
look in washington right now it is still
the washington redskins it's still you
know one of the more storied franchises
in the history of the nfl so that is
going to be appealing the other thing
that's always appealing to coaches is
the
there's nowhere to go but up factor and
that's one of the things that i think
will appeal to coaches as far as the
washington redskins conversation too you
know they've been bad and yeah only one
playoff appearance in six years and all
of those things with jay gruden to where
coaches are going to like that because
the expectations are not going to be
very high there
yeah
they're not going to be high but it
still feels like you're stepping into a
situation that is eventually going to
end badly for you especially if bruce
allen is still there it has been one
disaster after another one piece of
evidence of dysfunction after another
and really is there any other job in the
nfl right now that if you were weighing
that against the washington coaching job
you would have a hard time
deciding
which one you would take
any other no well you're just saying
like is there any other one where i'd go
oh okay i would take the well i mean at
this you know yeah okay the cincinnati
bengals might be in that conversation to
me a little bit all right i mean they're
in that convo right now yes um
but i would think no as as it looks
right now those are probably towards the
the bottom of the list as far as uh
appealing jobs out there to be a head
coach
well for now bill callahan is the
interim head coach in washington and
there's a new sheriff in town isn't that
a weird vibe that the guy who takes over
for the guy who got fired comes in with
this new attitude and he's doing all
these different things and it makes you
wonder how much he and the former coach
may have been at odds about how they
should handle the team because right out
of the gates bill callahan no music is
on after stretching they brought in
officials to issue penalties when guys
are sloppy in practice and
after practice
wind sprint time to ensure that the
players are better conditioned which
implies that bill callahan believed that
the players weren't in good enough
condition and that maybe that's
something that he and jay gruden were
loggerheads over well you know all the
assistant coaches sit there and they go
oh i would do this if i was in control i
mean there's even coaches probably in
new england who are saying that you know
oh i might do it this way but you know
whatever it may be and yeah here's a
chance bill callahan
he's taking over and he's changing a few
things that he obviously
thought needed to be changed now the
conditioning thing i really do find an
interesting aspect because this is
something i think you've heard me say
before mike that in the nfl uh teams do
not condition as the season goes it just
becomes oh the season's long it's a
grind oh you guys are in football shape
but you know the one team that does
condition throughout the year
you know do you want to guess who that
is
uh
jacksonville jaguars no you know hill
you jerk the new england pagers you're
such a jerk thank you play along okay
that's told me new england in the air
thanks stats yeah thanks so yes i mean
uh because they believe in four quarters
of football and and continuing to try to
play and mentally execute when you're
tired and things like that they're very
real aspects of football in the nfl and
uh i think because they're professionals
and you got some older men that some
teams do not kind of hold their players
to that same accountability that new
england does or bill callahan is about
to here in washington
it is weird though when you think about
it when you're a head coach and you have
a staff of assistants and this is why so
many coaches hire their kids hire their
friends they're looking for people they
can trust because it can quite easily
become a nest of vipers where you have a
bunch of guys who are waiting for the
opportunity to plunge a knife into your
back and take your job the instant they
have an opening and how do you operate
with sufficient trust when you're in
that and and it's so awkward those last
few weeks when you know it's coming
think about what's going on in atlanta
right now where it feels like the axe is
going to fall on dan quinn and you've
got raheem morris and mike malarkey and
dirk cutter all jockeying for position
and quinn knows if i go if arthur blank
wakes up on monday morning and says hit
the road it's going to be one of these
guys and what are they thinking and what
what what are they doing to actually
help me keep this job at this point or
are they thinking about hey maybe i'm
going to end up being the coach of the
falcons it's just a strange strange
dynamic but it plays out every year it
does it's strange dynamic certainly uh i
think what you know and it's natural
human you know emotions so yeah okay i
want to be the guy next i want to be the
head coach whatever it is but i think
what keeps everything in check is you
know if these coaches are too quick to
you know stick the knife in the back of
the head coach or those kind of people
uh they'll get a reputation in a hurry
for not being a loyal soldier within a
building and they'll have a hard time
ever getting a job anywhere else in the
nfl that's what keeps people in check
more than not that's that's one of the
issues between jim tomsula and your
buddy jim harbaugh jim harbaugh thinks
tomsula did it to him in san francisco
uh what it was you probably gave tom
solo the knife jim's already he's he
lost nine knives and 20 other backs
already so
um
do what percentage chance do you give
rex ryan of becoming the next coach in
washington uh a low percentage chance i
i you know pick a number okay i mean ten
percent that's it's that
yeah you're too high he's not getting
the job you're right he just would not
be the guy that i would want to take
over to kind of get things back in the
right direction there in washington rex
ryan's a little bit of a renegade
himself so i don't know if like
rebuilding and re-culturing an
organization if that's even a word is uh
his cup of tea
you know i i thought as you said it that
doesn't really sound like a word but you
know just keep going and nobody made it
put it in the dictionary
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports